chris is with us in Missouri hi Chris
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
thanks for having me today
sure what's up so I've recently started
watching you on YouTube and on your app
and following along with a lot of what
you've been saying my problem is trying
to talk to my wife about getting a
budget and doing I would like to do that
the seven baby steps but when we tried
the Condor what did it sound like when
we've talked about budgeting in the past
how long ago anywhere from when we first
started so I mean you just started
watching our stuff have you talked to
her since then no okay because it
started and say every time we've done it
it's done nothing but start a fight
where does it fight
where does the fight come from I I think
part of its insecurity because she
neither one of us had been great with
money prior to this we were three years
into a chapter 13 bankruptcy and we just
recently where we thought we were about
done with it just realized we've got
about a year left because we were behind
on it and it almost got cancelled on us
so and that just added more stress on
today so ordeal yeah so so Chris listen
you guys have the nerd word is trauma
you all have okay trauma around money
and some people try to solve trauma by
getting a plan and getting a why a
strong why this will never happen again
I am gonna go follow
plan that millions of people have
followed before and that's great man and
that's where you happen to be you
stumbled onto something that's a gift
and it sounds like you are want to make
some changes in your life that's gonna
affect your family tree and that's
awesome you going home to your wife and
saying hey you know what we should
probably be doing now is gonna set off
every alarm she's got in her head
because everything is going to be
chapter 13 chapter 13 and I thought we
were doing this and my husband told me
we had a plan and then I but you don't I
mean and so you're gonna have to circle
back around they've you've been down
this road before yep and Chris I can
tell you in in your voice I'm not
hearing a why I'm here another plan
another thing okay and I may be wrong
there but in my in my house the way it
sounded was this Sharon said I don't
want to hear another scheme I don't want
her no scam great because because
everything I've tried up to that point
felt like a scheme or a scam to her and
he were broke here we sit bankrupt with
a brand-new baby a toddler and they're
cutting the lights off and it terrified
her in it damaged me it made me ashamed
it made me feel guilty it made me feel
inept but it terrified her so how do you
how do you get past that fear well what
what amounted to was is that any ideas
that I had were not trustworthy because
I had not been trustworthy worthy of
trust because my actions brought nothing
but crap and so and here I come with
another truck you know as far as she's
concerned that's what she was hearing
and so it was by degrees and it was
holding hands and saying I'm not coming
to you with all the answers I'm coming
to you and saying this house doesn't run
well when it comes to money and so this
how
you and me baby we got to make some
changes I found this thing would you
walk into it with me investigate it with
me and see if we can work this together
and then she's not counting on you to
have provided the answer because
truthfully up to now your provision your
the answers you provided have not been
trustworthy that was true of me and
that's not because you're a bad guy it's
because you didn't know when you made
mistakes well that makes you humans all
okay so I'm not picking on you don't
misunderstand I'm trying to give you her
perspective and so what Sharon and I did
was I said okay in our case we were
faith people were Christians and I said
okay what I found is this guy's teaching
them what God says about money what the
Bible says about money because what dave
says about money sucks and I'm awful at
it and so we are gonna learn this
together and we are gonna walk out of
this mess together and we are never
going back in and then she walked into
that and as she learned it as I learned
it together then she wasn't looking at
the plan through the lens of Dave she
was looking at it through her own lens
because she was beside me walking into
this that's different then I've got a
plan for us again does that make sense
yeah yeah I think that in in Chris I
hear in your voice this can you just get
over it
can we just get on with it and Dave I
don't want to speak into into you and
Sharon's life but my guess is if there's
a couple of weeks of not talking about
something or if maybe a couple of months
at this point or if you mention a couple
of things or if she if Sharon happens to
see a real estate magazine open at a
hotel you know that those alarms are
gonna go off no matter how far away how
many zeros are in your checking account
so Chris when is she just gonna get over
it probably never it will be small and
it will it will it will turn into a
trickle and yeah what your trust will
grow but man people don't grieve at the
same pace and the more you say why don't
you just why don't you just man that
just builds a deeper and deeper wedge in
your relationship you're in this
together man you know you're in it
together so
one struck once Humpty Dumpty's busted
once trust is busted
it's hard to rebuild it it takes time
and I mean you think about if if I've
got a team member here and they they
misbehave in a certain area and I go
well okay I can't trust him in the same
level and I don't hold that against him
for five years but I am going to be
watching them for that behavior until
they prove that that behavior is not a
pattern in their life and so it takes
time of the two of you working together
and the more distance you put between
yourself and the past stupidity the more
the trust is being rebuilt and so my
stoop my super stupid eye my PhD in D um
be that I got was you know thirty years
ago and so it's in the distant rearview
mirror there's still tender spot still
scars in our relationship from it but
it's I'm much more worthy of trust now
and have proven it thirty years worth
versus the seven prior to that look
celebrating 38 years this week as a
matter of fact gradually Sam and she
tells us that you know we've got thirty
good years America
[Laughter]